[Musique]
les nominés de la catégorie révélation
interprète instrumental de l'année
son salut je m'appelle mère mauroy j'ai
29 ans je suis musicien pianiste
martiniquais
je vis à boston peugeot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
j'ai commencé la musique le piano avec
ma mère pendant quelque temps qu'était
donc mon premier professeur de piano et
puis ensuite mes parents m'ont inscrit
dans des écoles de musique j'ai j'ai pu
être au contact de différentes
épaisseurs de piano en particulier
toujours
j'ai été notamment élèves de claude
césaire de sylvie and their de gaston
gobron luther françois et et plein
d'autres encore
[Musique]
on ne
je m'appelle nicolas lawson musicien
martiniquais walkley noir guitariste
chanteur je vais sortir un album qui
s'appelle pied au courant qu'ils
racontent un petit peu notre histoire
[Musique]
mais
dans ce métier là et a qu'une solution
pour y arriver c'est de pas avoir peur
du boulot il faut vraiment avoir
beaucoup de cordes à son arc si on veut
espérer de vivre de musique dans le
monde dans lequel on vit là maintenant
et je pense que je suis vraiment pas mal
de choses différentes
et au final je passe très peu de temps
avec l'instrument
[Musique]
simard cabreira jeune pianiste de 25 ans
et je ne représentons humide à 2017
ce professeur de piano à l'office
culturel de ducos à l'office culturel du
lamentin et je donne des cours
d'initiation à l'improvisation dans
l'association musiques plurielles au
robert
oh
je suis pianiste jazz j'ai la chance de
jouer sur des scènes prestigieuses de la
vente unique comme le biguine jazz mais
je me produis aussi sur les dents les
bas et cetera donc j'essaie de
fait reconnaître tout en jouant la
musique du pays a commenté de quelques
touches de diaz
et
m
[Musique]